in the opening scene we are taken to a
secluded and distant Forest compound
which is owned by a polygamist sect the
community's revered leader known as the
shepherd is the sole male figure and the
women in the group worship Him
expressing gratitude for accepting them
as His Wives come with me inside the
deluded Mind of a daydreaming Andrew
Tate within this cult the women are
categorized into two groups the
daughters dressed in various shades of
blue and the wives dressed in reddish
use the community's main activities
involve raising Lambs for sustenance and
sacrificial rituals the scene then
shifts to the shepherd having a meal
together with all of his wives and
daughters after finishing his food he
selects one of his wives to spend the
night with the next morning the shepherd
accompanied by all of his wives and
daughters gathers in a courtyard while
delivering a sermon one of the daughters
named Sila remains fixated on him
without even blinking she appears to
have a strong admiration towards the
shepherd after sermon they engage in
prayer during which the shepherd dips
his hand into the blood of a sacrificed
lamb and smears it on the faces of his
wives and daughters later on as Cela and
her friend Tamar are standing in the
woods they are captivated by The
Shepherd's presence from a distance in
particular Sila wants to have a private
conversation with him so she cleverly
sends her friend to attend to some
household tasks after this Sila walks
with the shepherd who compliments her
beauty and draws parallels between her
charm and that of her deceased mother
who passed away during her birth in
response Sila asks how he met her mother
in the first place she is curious if
they were involved in a romantic
relationship however instead of
answering her question the shepherd
playfully touches her hair and tries to
get closer to her but at the last second
he swiftly changes the subject and
requests Sila to re-braid her hair
before they part ways later that day one
of the wives named Eloise shares a
romantic story with Sila and another
daughter she explains that she had an
intense coitusession Shepherd upon
hearing this Sila who Harbors affection
for the shepherd becomes envious and
responds to Eloise in a harsh manner the
other daughter intervenes reminding Sila
that they are not permitted to speak to
the wives with such a tone nonetheless
Selah denies this rule arguing that
Eloise is of the same age as them
shortly after another wife enters the
scene and the daughter reports Sila's
rude Behavior to Eloise as a consequence
Sila is assigned to the task of
delivering leftover food to a small
dimly lit hot or menstruating women are
secluded due to the belief that they are
impure inside the hut Sila encounters
two unhealthy women and engages in a
conversation with one of them named
Sarah the latter whose chest Bears scars
warns Sila about the shepherd's acts of
violence she asserts that once Sila
enters the menstrual cycle the shepherd
will treat her in the worst possible way
however Sila dismisses the warning and
she still perceives the shepherd to be a
good person the same night as she is
putting her younger sisters to bed she
looks out the window and notices the
shepherd engaging in Romance with one of
his wives this makes her really jealous
but she can't do anything about it in
the morning the wives assist the
Shepherd in bathing and one of them
informs him that a new lamb is about to
take birth in another room two other
wives help Sila clean herself because
she is going to be with the Shepherds
soon it is then revealed that the lamb
mentioned by the wives earlier is none
other than Sila herself in the next
scene we see Silas sitting alone in the
peaceful Fields eventually drifting off
into sleep she awakens to the sound of
lambs nearby and Rises to investigate
the herdismay she discovers one of the
Lambs severely injured and on the brink
of death bleeding profusely in a
distressing turn of events Sila realizes
that she too is bleeding traveled by
this Revelation she examines herself
later that night but doesn't find any
answers she can't even fall asleep due
to the continuous bleeding tomorrow who
is by Silas side notices her distress
and inquires about what happened Sila
makes up a story stating that she dozed
off in the field during which a wild dog
attacked and killed one of the Lambs she
goes on to say that the wives took her
to the shepherd who generously forgave
her for the incident the following night
Sila is jolted by the sound of a police
car siren prompting her to peep through
the window overhearing a conversation
between a police officer and the
shepherd she learns that their group
must Evacuate the premises the officer
grants them a limited amount of time to
comply or else they will have to face
legal actions in response the shepherd
gathers all his wives and daughters the
next morning to deliver the sad news he
explains that they must leave their
current location to avoid the potential
destruction broad by the outside world
which could tear them apart he also
announces his intention to lead them in
search of a new home this Revelation sat
in Selah and while she is sitting alone
the shepherd approaches her offering
words of encouragement and emphasizing
the importance of her strength for the
sake of the numerous young daughters who
depend on her following this the cult
assembles with their belongings and
engages in a collective prayer before
embarking on a long journey in search of
their new home they travel through
forests and mountains walking for an
entire day until they reach a spot where
they decide to camp and spend the night
in the woods during that night Sila
experiences a nightmare envisioning
herself immersed in water alongside two
other daughters she also Witnesses the
shepherd slitting the throat of a lamb
early in the morning they resume their
journey and after a considerable
duration they stumble upon an abandoned
house Sila and some other women enter to
inspect the premises but the shepherd
declares that they cannot stay there
because it is a broken house made by
broken people as a result they set their
tents outside the house preparing for
another night in the
the following morning Sila displays
signs of illness vomiting and appearing
unwell later on she secretly examines
the blood on her thighs only to be
noticed by one of the daughters this
makes the latter scream in fear and she
shouts that Sila has become impure as a
result the poor girl is compelled to
join a group of banished wives anybody
else feeling that this is basically just
a ripoff of Toy Story that evening Stila
engages in conversation with Sarah who
discloses that she was one of the
shepherd's first two wives the other one
was none other than Silas mother Sarah
explains that initially the shepherd
used to show her favor but now he has
become rude and hostile to her he always
punished her for no reason when Sila
expresses skepticism Sarah compares the
shepherd's attention to the sun
initially radiant and glorious but
eventually causing them to burn as their
conversation continues Sarah reveals the
truth to Selah that her mother did not
die during her birth but rather
succumbed to an infection a few days
later she explains that the shepherd did
not take her to the hospital viewing it
as a test of her faith and resulting in
her death from sepsis furthermore Sarah
admits that she no longer holds faith in
the shepherd but still stays in the cult
due to a lack of Alternatives and fear
of being alone in the next scene the
cult continues their Journey alongside a
country road during this Sila catches
sight of a passing car with three people
inside she fantasizes herself within the
vehicle dressed like a regular teenager
which brings her to tears that night
they all make camp at a certain spot and
while they have their dinner Sela gaze
is at a pregnant Eloise who also stares
back at her while gently caressing her
belly the next day during the difficult
hike Eloise suddenly goes into labor the
other wives believe it is time for birth
but Eloise is unable to gather the
courage to do so she fears that the baby
will die in this treacherous
environments however when the other
wives force her she pushes hard and
eventually gives birth in the process
though she sadly loses own life after
the incident the group prepares for
Eloise's funeral during which Sarah
confronts the shepherd and holds him
accountable for the woman's demise she
even addresses him by his real name
Michael however the shepherd dismisses
her accusations and walks away after the
funeral Sarah confides in Selah
informing her that she and Eloise's baby
are departing from the cult she reveals
that the shepherd wants the newly born
infant to die believing that the baby is
somehow flawed Sila struggles to
comprehend the shepherd's reasoning and
Sarah discloses that it is because the
infant is
Shepherd does not want any other males
in the Cults other than himself with
this Sarah bids farewell to Sila and
departs from the group the remaining
members of the community continue
following the shepherd's lead although
exhaustion looms over them after days of
non-stop walking later they take a short
break and sit on the ground to rest at
that moment Tamar points out a potential
location suggesting that they explore it
but this only enrages Shepard as he
believes that no other leader should
exist aside from himself in a fit of
rage he kicks and physically assaults
Tamar witnessing this brutal act Silas
trust in the shepherd begins to crumble
and she recalls Sarah's earlier warnings
about him and he seemed so nice until
now after a long and arduous Journey
they finally reach a forested valley
with a large lake which the shepherd
proclaims to be their new sacred place
this makes the women somewhat happy as
they are tired to death in the evening
the shepherd performs a re-baptism
ritual submerging the older daughters
the water when it comes to seala's turn
the shepherd forcefully holds her
underwater for an extended period in
that moment Selah has a vision of him
attempting to drown her that's not a
vision Selah that is that's happening to
you right now later while gathered
around the campfire the wives abstain
from dinner explaining that they are
fasting in preparation for an upcoming
ritual the next day during the same
night the daughters are sleeping in a
tent when the shepherd summons Sila to
his own tent Tamar warns her not to go
but Sila disregards the advice once
inside the shepherd's tent he instructs
her to lie down he proceeds to touch
sela's body and forcefully assaults her
after satisfying his desires he bids her
good night and departs unfortunately
this leaves a deep Scar and seal his
mind and she envisions a scenario in
which all the daughters unite to
overthrow and kill the shepherd the
following morning the daughters wake up
only to discover that all the wives are
missing in search of their mothers they
head down to the lake where they find
the shepherd kneeling near the Disco
guarded Robes of the wives when they
inquire about the whereabouts of their
mothers the shepherd says that they have
ascended into a new existence and now it
is the daughter's duty to take their
place he singles at Sila designating her
as his wife however Sila fearlessly
confronts him claiming that he is not
their Shepherd and she does not want his
grace this enrages the shepherd
prompting him to smack her but in a
shocking Act of defiance she stands her
ground and slaps his ass back in the
aftermath of these events two police
officers discovered the dead bodies of
the wives washed ashore on the Lake's
Edge shocked they ventured deep into the
woods to find more cluths clues I mean
to their horror to discover the lifeless
body of the shepherd suspended between
two trees adorned with Ram's horns
placed on his head like a fawn in the
final scene the daughters gather
together at a waterfall while Sila
cradles a baby lamb in her arms
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching